Anthony is with us in Tucson Arizona hi
Anthony how are you I'm doing good
I'm very happy to be talking with you
Dave you too sir thank you for calling
in how can I help um so I just started
listening to you and read complete guide
to money about a month ago okay and I
got my wife on board and we're all for
this and I think we have a pretty good
plan ahead but we talked about doing SPU
and but I know that it kind of I guess
states-based I'm 80 since she's agnostic
is this something that would still
benefit us well it certainly will
benefit you there's any question about
that um and you're more than welcome
everyone's welcome to the class
Financial Peace University is the the
quote it's not just faith-based it's
Christian based and it will be taught in
a church that's where you would be
attending I mean I just want you to know
what you're getting into but you're more
than welcome eiope lots of people that
you know are agnostic or atheist or just
hadn't thought about it or you know they
go to a different denomination than
where the church is being held so they
don't always agree with everything going
on in the church roof you know that kind
of thing or you know we've had I had
some couple Muslim guys come through our
entre leadership training the other day
I got to sit and talk to them it was
awesome and but everybody's welcome I'm
not mad at anybody so you're more than
welcome and I think you'll find the
class the people teaching the class to
be friendly and welcoming to you I think
just to kind of give you a guideline of
the fact that you would call my show and
ask me about this tells me you're not
someone walking around with a chip on
your shoulder just looking to be
offended all the time
no not at all okay and so I mean if
you're one of those then you're probably
going to find something to be offended
about right but but and I don't think
you are I think if you read you saw
faith and you saw Scripture mentioned in
complete guide to money right sir yeah
and if you were not offended by that and
received instruction from your worldview
in spite of that it would be the right
way of saying
that gasps then and you're you know you
saw value in that then you'd probably
have a pretty similar experience in
Financial Peace University okay they
don't they don't force you to get on
your knees and pray before the class
starts you know we don't ask we tell
people not to do that as a matter of
fact not that there's anything wrong
with that from our perspective but it's
not it's a financial class it's based on
biblical things but so is a complete
guide to money as a matter of fact
complete guide to money is the handbook
that comes in the Financial Peace
University class that's what I found out
and I think I got to look handed to me
so okay really helped us out a lot
though I'm glad I'm glad it helps you
and you're more again you're more than
welcome you're going to see about that
same level of Christianity woven into
the class in that as a Christian I my
faith into anything I teach anywhere I
am but hopefully not doing it in a way
that's so freakin overbearing that it's
lit that makes you lose your taste for
it because I want to help you to you
know know and I haven't felt that way at
all listening to you or reading the
books okay cool well that that's
probably what you're going to get unless
the coordinator just decides to get
overzealous waiting class but but
generally the actual content in the
videos would be about the same level
with the exception of the last lesson
which is a tithing lesson on giving but
if you just convert that from tithing to
giving in your mind as you're hearing it
you probably will get instruction from
that as well okay amen thanks for the
call
and I hope I hope you enjoy the class
this is the Dave Ramsey show